it's show time in Edinburgh
every summer performers from around the
world flock to the Fringe the world's
largest Arts Festival for the Scots it's
a welcome distraction from their worries
about brexit
though politics has a place here to at
least as parody back said you know if
I'd been dealing with Brett said a long
time ago we would have been do you
Europe and the UK would have been
separated a long time ago there would
have been a huge world huge war along
the French coast I would have had like
you know that's what we look to do look
to divide places are that still symbolic
that's a kilt maker Gordon Nicholson
brexit is no laughing matter
Britain's imminent exit from the EU is
already hurting business a complete
outfit costs around a thousand pounds
but now his clients are hesitant to
place orders due to the ongoing
uncertainty the kilt maker is fed up
with Britain's politicians he believes
Prime Minister Boris Johnson's brexit
plans are plunging the UK into chaos
even EU one cos we don't know what
what's going to happen we have no idea
and no deal or T has been put in place
so we are just hoping that things are
going to be okay that's not a way to run
the country it's not a way to run a
business for many Scots the kilt is an
expression of their own identity or even
of their own nation membership in a
Scottish National Party has been rising
and according to a recent poll some 52
percent of Scots are now in favour of
Scottish independence also sees this as
the right move we are determined nation
we have shown over the years that we are
innovative and if we went independent
not strengths of character and strengths
of belief and what we we can produce and
believe in we'd certainly and take us
through the whole thing
while many Scots are turning their backs
on Britain this sentiment is especially
strong in the Scottish capital in the
2014 referendum on Scottish independence
some two-thirds of voters in Edinburgh
voted to stay in the UK but since the
brexit vote the mood has changed
dramatically well-educated young people
in particular don't want to see their
career path blocked due to brexit Finlay
MacFarlane spent her semester studying
in the Czech Republic and recently
travelled across Europe by train he
feels that British government has let
him down whole new demographic of people
are starting to question actually maybe
independence is the way forwards and
especially voting for young people like
me like giving your vote for the future
of Scotland and and are we stuck with
another conservative Prime Minister that
Scotland didn't vote for and that's been
going on for years and years and years
now and and how is that fair out of the
UK into the EU that would be a big
mistake at least according to this
Scottish Labour Party MP independence at
this moment in time is possibly the
worst moment you could be contemplating
it and it would it would actually
magnify the the consequences that we're
facing because of brexit but the other
fundamental point is it's what what
precedent does that there establish in
terms of allowing a seceding states and
and I think that will be a question and
a lot of government government's Minds
across Europe not to mention that the
British Parliament would have to consent
to Scotland holding a second referendum
on independence
one hot favorite at this year's Fringe
Festival is this flame bearing Bank
Piper
how timely now that the British and
Scottish governments are playing with
fire